Mal erkennen, Stream ist on, und, na.
Boah, erst mal Twitter, Twitter's Post hin.
Vielleicht sollte ich den Titel noch so was reinschreiben, wie German Stream oder sowas.
Vielleicht bringt das was.
Was meint ihr Leute, falls schon jemand da ist?
Meint ihr es ist sinnvoll, wenn ich irgendwie German oder sowas oder DE oder sonst irgendwie sowas in Titel schreibe?
Weil die ganzen Noobs, also die, die noch schlechter sind als ich, die gucken ja immer nach deutschen Streams.
Meint ihr das bringt was?
Ja, wir schreiben da noch DE rein.
Mein Handy macht Geräusche.
Mein Handy hat komische Geräusche gemacht. Oder war das Deins?
Weiß ja nicht, ob von der einen Tischhälfte zur anderen drüber das aufgenommen wird.
Weiß ich, es hat sich angehört für mein Handy, aber es war nicht meins, als ich jetzt drauf geguckt habe.
Es hat halt gerade vibriert.
War das mal Deins, oder?
Ja.
Na gut, hast du es auf dem Tisch stehen, dein Mikrofon? Dann überträgt das ja.
Das ist doch zwar Activation, ne?
Ja.
Ah ja, Tim Lampe, das ist eine gute Idee.
Keine Dings, keine Mikrofon-Spinnen.
Ja, alles klar bei mir. Moin King Chris und Tim Lampe.
Ja, ich mach noch Ger-Entitel.
Mercy, Mercy mein Only Stream heute. Nein.
Ich spiele nur Mercy, wenn es gar nicht anders geht.
Enden wir den Titel mal, ich mach vorne das so in eckigen Klammern.
Das macht der Kami auch immer, der weiß, was er macht.
Ja, das war's.
Ja, jetzt stimmt's, okay.
Twitch, Logik.
Aber alle mal besser als auf YouTube, die Settings.
Das ist mittlerweile so verhunzt.
Brauchst 30 Untermenüs und 50 Profilseiten, dass du das findest, was du suchst.
Was meinst du jetzt besser im Titel DE oder Ger?
Was deut... äh, eindeutiger?
Wenn die Leute nach deutsch suchen, DE, hä?
Germanisch.
Germanisch, das ist eine halbe Titel weg.
Machen wir einfach mal so hier, zack.
Bam.
Easy.
Easy clap.
Richtig, die Modes sind auch an, jawoll.
Moin, Raffi.
JustSonicKutz.
Und die Ananas.
Und General Slane, auch da.
Auf geht's.
Ich invite dich.
Mein Handy benachrichtigt, dass Leute auf Twitter meine Post liken.
Das macht's normalerweise nie.
Das sind dann meistens Leute, die viele Follower haben.
Da muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Aha, jemand von Twitch hat mein Tweet geliked.
Oh mein Gott.
So, ähm, damit ich's sage, legen wir mal los, ne?
Mhm.
Ich poste das jetzt noch.
Ich such schon mal ein Game.
Wir müssen uns eh erstmal einspielen wieder.
Ah.
Alter.
Ich hab wieder übelst kalte Hände.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, aber...
Ah.
Erstmal zwei Runden aufwärmen. Ich queue.
Ich poste das mal auf YouTube wieder.
Ja, bei mir ist heute besser.
Ich glaube, YouTube hat nicht...
Hat sich das anders vorgestellt.
Diese, diese Posting-Funktion,
anstatt dass man damit seinen Twitch-Screen bewirbt.
Ich glaube, YouTube hatte damit andere Sachen vor, ehrlich gesagt.
Also, das übliche...
Blah, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Umfragen.
Oder, oder neue Videos.
Oder sonst was.
In meinen letzten drei Posts auf YouTube
streamen wir jetzt Offerware-Streng-Twitch.
Schaut vorbei.
Dann müsst ihr mal einen Tweet raushauen
an YouTube.
Nein, bloß nicht.
Bloß nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist immer noch Experimental-Feature.
Dann deaktivieren sie das wieder.
Hast du es schon in T500 geschafft?
Nein, gestern haben wir Master gemacht.
Mit 7 zu 2, muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Wir haben 7 Gems gewonnen, 2 verloren.
Trotzdem gerade so Master.
So.
Bin wieder auf Twitch.
On...
Nee, jetzt haben wir live
mit Offerware.
Haben wir gestern echt nur 2 verloren?
Wir haben 3 verloren, wenn man das...
Nee, 4 verloren,
wenn man das Aufwärmen mitzählt.
Die ersten zwei Matches, wo wir gesagt haben,
wir erstmal warm spielen, haben wir direkt auf den Sack gekriegt.
Ich dachte doch gerade, das kam mir ein bisschen...
Nee, wir haben ein bisschen mehr verloren.
Aber nachdem wir erst eingespielt waren,
haben wir am Ende 7 zu 2.
Wobei egal.
Ich habe eh mehr Punkte gemacht,
das ist mies.
Aber so richtig.
Ich glaube, das Wurf ist jetzt auf dem Hardstock aus.
Ich picke mal
gleich irgendwie...
Ich logg erst mal rein,
hat ein Wurf, um mir sicher zu gehen, dass keiner
irgendwelche komischen Dinger macht jetzt mit, dass ich wieder Mercy spielen muss.
Ansonsten kann ich immer noch
Twitchen.
Ich muss erst mal jetzt die YouTube-Message schicken.
Bin wieder live auf Twitch mit Offerware-Training.
Gestern wieder Master gepackt.
Endlich wieder, gestern...
Endlich wieder Master gepackt.
Beitrag erstellen.
Nice.
Ist jetzt funktioniert?
Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn die das bei YouTube
wieder abschalten, wenn sie feststellen, dass ich die Leute
von anderen Zeiten benutze.
Ist ein Mod gerade am Start?
Eine der Mods am Start.
Die sind ganz schön früh am Start, 15.40 Uhr unter der Woche.
Was ist da los? Habt ihr Urlaub?
Sind schon Schulferien?
Also, Frage in die Runde.
Kriegt das dann immer richtig mit?
Du bist immer da, MrFryGuy.
Nice.
Oh.
Gehämmert.
Pschuuu.
Was? Die sind ausgewischen.
Was?
Alter.
Ah, ist schon 25% Shatter.
Schild bricht gleich, ich muss weg.
Nice, nice.
Puschen, Puscherino, go, go, go.
Ich baite mal Hock, ich baite mal Hock.
Ha, ha, lull.
Nope.
Ja, ich gehe mal nicht hinterher.
Lass das mal sicher durchpuschen.
Wer weiß.
Sie fallen um die Ecke, Junkrat spammt mich weg.
Ich konnte es denaten.
Gibt nix.
Wir haben Golden Boy im Team.
Bestimmt der echte Woodface.
Ach, Roadhog.
Du triffst da gar nix.
Ich will, ich will Shatter aufladen.
70.
Ha, ha, der Roadhog, der wird schön gebaitet mit den Hooks.
Nein.
90 Shatter.
Junkrat ist weg, ist weg, ist weg.
Oder auch nicht.
Wir kriegen auf den Sack.
Mal Shatter baiten.
Falls er hat.
Wow, WTF.
Ich verpiss mich mal.
Rechts ist ein Roadhog alleine.
Ich habe nur noch 600 Schild.
Ich habe Shatter am Strack.
Gleich Leute, Huge Shatter kommt jetzt gleich.
Der müsste auch Shatter haben, der Reinhard.
Ich baite das Ding mal, ich versuche.
Oh, Hook.
Wo kommt der Teil aus?
Kann man nicht treffen.
Fuck man.
Oh, ich schliepe.
Nee, da geht nix.
Haben wir eine Mercy?
Ach, wir haben keine Mercy, deswegen geht es nicht vorwärts.
No Mercy, no win.
Leute, so ist das halt.
Also der Roadhog lässt sich easy baiten.
Der Hook, ja.
Ich schlafe und der könnte Shattern gleich.
Der muss Shatter haben.
Nice, der Reinhard ist down, wird gerätzt.
Der wird gleich Shattern, 100 pro.
Er ist aber down.
Wieder gerätzt, Mensch.
What the fuck.
Einfach pushen.
Progress machen.
Was ist denn hier los?
Über mir, über mir.
Wir müssen ein bisschen mehr zusammenstehen.
Und wir brauchen eine Mercy.
No Mercy, no win.
Ich gehe gleich Winston.
Wir haben nix zu melden auf dem High Ground aktuell.
Gar nix.
Pass auf, du bist alleine vorne.
Nein, er hat mich eingeklemmt.
Schild bricht.
Der Roadhog lässt sich aber echt easy baiten.
Ich hab gleich wieder Shatter am Start.
Da sind 30 Milliarden Gegner.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich was erwischt hab.
Ich hab den Roadhog.
Nein, ich schlafe, ich schlafe.
Haben wir eine Mercy mittlerweile?
Das könnte noch funktionieren.
Ich nehme mal ein bisschen was mobileres.
Huge Shatter war das gerade wieder.
Schöne Chill dran.
Aber es geht nicht wirklich vorwärts.
Ganz aufs Dach hoch.
Matrix ist leer.
Ich bleib auf dem Dach.
Der Junkrat spammt.
Sag, wenn ihr unten wieder am Start seid.
Dann komm ich raus.
Das ganze Dach ist voll.
Die stehen alle auf dem Dach.
Nice, nice.
Ich geh rein.
Der McCree fällt zurück.
Wo kommt denn jetzt der Junkrat her?
Ok, Roadhog ist weg.
McCree ist nach oben.
Hinter euch.
Sehen wir durch.
Hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ich guck gleich in den Chat.
Erstmal die Runde.
Ich gewinn.
Der Roadhog, will der flanken?
Oder was mit dem los?
Kannst du mich ruhig rücken, Roadhog?
Hab ich nix dagegen.
Nein, hilf mir.
Wo ist das Tyra?
Weiß ich nicht.
Hab ihn.
Die Mercy retzt.
Nein, 4% vor Ulti.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Ich brauche mal ein Auto wieder.
Irgendetwas ist rechts.
Irgendetwas hab ich rechts noch gehört.
Gleich wieder Auto.
Fuck.
Das war zu viel.
Der Rez rettet sowas von dem Arsch jedes Mal.
Regroup.
Ob's besser noch in Group Chat.
Ich lieg da gleich dran.
Ich lieg da gleich dran und Ulti.
Boah, nix getroffen.
Von hinten, von hinten.
Zarya ist fast down.
Ich bin dran, ich bin dran.
Ja, kriegt man nicht.
No Mercy, no win.
Boah, jetzt haben sie es aber übertrieben.
Ich meine, jetzt können wir Defenden.
Das geht, weil wir das gut machen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall zu gewinnen.
Erstmal Crosshair ändern.
Dann machen wir hier Discord kurz und muss mal Chat gucken.
So, was hab ich dir im Chat übersehen?
Top 500? Nein, Verwaltem nicht.
Gestern erst mal war Master wieder.
Ich hab jetzt als Season 3 nicht gespielt.
Ja, Loris, 3500, gestern erreicht.
3520, das heißt, wenn wir jetzt verlieren, steigen wir gleich wieder ab.
Soll ich Mercy picken? Nein.
Ah, oder? Doch, komm.
Jetzt hier.
Pass mal auf, huge Mercy Plays, Leute.
Huge Mercy Plays.
Neuer Mercy, Mercy Main.
So, was hab ich noch überlesen?
Wann gibt es wieder Battlefield 3?
Es gab letztens ein Battlefield 3 Stream.
Vor ein paar Tagen, gar nicht so lange her.
Ich finde das schon ein bisschen witzig, weil eigentlich hat ja Mercy so gesehen,
den Platz von Symmetra genommen.
Den nützlichen TP zu nutzen.
Stimmt, ja.
Ich muss gerade noch mal kurz Chat lesen.
Ich hab viel verpasst.
Hey, Max, na wie hängts?
Ich bin ja nicht winzend.
Heute nur 9-10. Ah, das, okay.
9-10, 9-12, nice.
9-12 Schule und dann Schluss.
So.
Ich muss jetzt erstmal wieder vorlaufen.
Dann bin ich nochmal rechtzeitig da.
Schließt gleich weiter, Chat.
Oh, fuck, Münzen.
Da hab ich jetzt gar keinen Bock drauf.
Oh, fuck.
Ich werde hier echt Probleme haben, klar.
Mit Münzen und Genji.
Die haben voll auf mich abgesehen.
Ich damage boost dich mal.
Der Genji von links, von links.
Auf unsere Ana.
Der weiß auf jeden Fall, wo ich bin.
Du kriegst boost.
Ich sehe bloß gerade nichts.
Die war hinter uns.
Wir müssen runter, wir müssen runter.
Leute, wir müssen runter.
Droppt.
Münzen ist hochgesprungen.
Das heißt, er hat jetzt erstmal keinen Jump.
Geh gleich drauf.
Nope.
Die Ana könnte ich ja auch mal heilen, ne?
Das wäre ja auch nochmal im Bereich des Möglichen.
Ich verstecke mich mal in der Ecke.
Sag, wenn ihr daneben Hilfe braucht.
Ich bin im Häuschen.
Vom Helzpack.
90%...
D.va flankt.
Wir müssen jetzt bloß gucken, dass sie nicht durchpushen,
in der Zeit, wo wir hier flanken, Reno machen.
Gleich Ulti, gleich Ulti.
1% noch.
Nice.
Damage boost.
Das war nur ein Reinhardt.
Sag mal mal, was du siehst.
Ich traue mich nicht, rauszugucken gegen Genji und Münzen.
Nee, die haben geswitcht.
Mit Hef.
Nee, die haben geswitcht. Mit Hef.
Aber eine D.va haben sie jetzt.
Okay, ich geh runter.
Ich geh mal runter.
Ah nein.
Ich hab dich.
Die pushen durch.
McCree ist links durch.
Ja, ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen.
Wo ist hier was gestorben? Ist schon was gestorben?
Wo ist da Hochhallen?
Ich sag ja noch Hochhallen.
Ist doch die Mercy abends frühstücken und gut ist.
Ja, die D.va ist halt rechts hinter uns noch.
Warst du im Markt stand hier?
Irgendwo?
Ja.
Und aus dem Mephag.
Wo steckst du?
Suchst du die?
Oh fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. Unsere Ana kriegt aufs Maul.
Kommt raus.
Ich versuch zu retten.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Ich krieg von hinten, von hinten die D.va hinter mir.
Nee, schön getifet.
Gute Zeit.
Nicht gute Zeit.
Max, wie gehts? Gut?
Wieder Master.
Nach 6 Monaten nicht spielen.
Dank Eax Carry.
Alles kein Ding.
Wir können doch mal contesten.
Ja, wenn du schnell machst.
Ja, einer von euch muss ran. Die Ana geht ran.
Okay, nice.
Ich bin da. Die sind nämlich auch nicht dran.
Gucken, vielleicht kriegst du einen schönen Pick.
D.va rechts.
D.va flankt rechts. Achtung.
Ich bleib auf dir mit Damage Boost.
Aber die D.va kommt gleich wieder um die Ecke.
Ja, die ist rechts, da schon.
Nice Pick.
Sehr, sehr nice Pick.
Nice Defense.
Oben die Mercy.
Murky.
Reinhard, na komm.
Ich bitte dich.
Nice.
So kanns weitergehen, oder?
Hoffentlich nicht.
Ich hab mitten im Badge kalt geworden.
Meine Hände sind immer noch kalt.
So, jetzt muss ich mal chat gucken.
Ich mut mich Discord nochmal kurz.
Was hab ich verpasst hier, chat?
Twitch schauen mehr Studenten,
Youtube schauen mehr Schüler.
Weiß nicht.
Hast du deine Statistik zu?
Ich glaub sowohl Youtube als auch Twitch schauen alle.
Twitch vielleicht weniger.
Also ich glaub bei den älteren Leuten,
sagen wir so,
40 plus oder so,
40, 45 plus, die glaube ich
schauen eher Youtube als Twitch.
Sogar Rentner schauen Youtube, aber die schauen
wahrscheinlich eher kein Twitch.
Hampi, moin.
Das erste Mal da, schaue seit Jahren deine Videos.
Das ist doch nice.
Keyform ist auch am Start.
No Second Plan ist auch wieder da.
Max, machst du auf deinem Smurf
auch 6er Viewer ranked?
Das ist...
Das ist ja gar nicht so wirklich mein Smurf.
Mein Main Account ist seit
Season 3 herrlich
gerankt. Und das interne
Matchmaking ist einfach viel zu hoch für mich.
Gestern nur am Gewinnen, heute nur am
Verlieren. Ja das ist
doof, Hero. Aber
statistisch gesehen...
Ja, ich queue.
Aber statistisch gesehen,
wenn du lange genug spielst, gleicht sich das wieder aus.
Auch wenn es mega frustrierend ist.
Am besten ist du hörst auf.
Wenn es dir so auf den Sack geht, dass du gar keinen Bock
mehr hast weiter zu spielen, ist am besten du machst mal Pause.
Solo Queue ist echt eine Qual.
Ja, das ist richtig. Deswegen gebe ich mir auch
Solo Queue nicht, aber wir spielen zu zweit.
Hattest du nicht von der Zeit mal keinen Bock mehr auf Overwatch?
Ja.
Aber Solo hätte ich da auch keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Aber zu zweit ist das wirklich ganz
spaßig.
Das hält sich so ein bisschen die Waage, weißt du.
Da kann man sich dann immer noch so ein bisschen gegenseitig
gut zureden.
Max, hast du eine
mechanische Tastatur? Nein.
Nein.
Nicht mechanische Tastatur. Nein.
Aber ich muss mir demnächst eine neu holen.
Ich finde das immer merkwürdig.
Wie er Callout für Team gibt, aber genau
mit Eaxenoid redet.
Das ist ja erstmal der wichtigste, der es hören muss.
Was nimmt Eax ͠u für наконец.
Eax, wieviel nimmst du für Carrien
auf Emma Multiplase?
Fragt der Chat.
exhausted
Also die Saal-Zulage, die Frust-Zulage, die Depression, die Tabletten die ich dafür brauche
Das wird teuer, hä?
Ja, wird heftig teuer
Brauchen wir Support? Komm wir spielen Support
Komm wir machen jetzt mal hier das krasse Healer-Duo
Soll ich Anna spielen? Oder was willst du denn haben als zweiten Support?
Ähm
Speed, hä?
Also mir ist es egal
Was du willst
Ja, Speed bringt immer was
Wobei, naja
Kommst du mit Zen klar, ansonsten nehme ich Zen
So TH ist da
Hi, moin
Von Support-DD und Tank, was spielst du am wenigsten?
DD, DPS spiele ich kaum
Ab und zu mal Soldier
Na gut, ich meine Reaper
Zielen und klicken
Aber ich spiele die ganze DPS-Sparte mit Abstand am wenigsten
Ich spiele eigentlich hauptsächlich die hier
So, ah, diese Ecke
Leute, was ist denn dieses komische Symbol oben links, was manchmal aufplaut?
Dieser Blitz, das Reload-Symbol und der Blitz
Ist das Packet-Lost oder ist das Server-Lag oder was ist das?
Oh, jetzt bin ich Zen, jetzt muss ich aufpassen
Also von Reinhardt auf Zen-Switch ist wirklich schwierig
Genji, du kriegst den Heal-Orb, nope, kriegste nicht
Ich spamm Schild, die Orissa ist ziemlich low an Point
Ich soll wohl der Backline holen
Was geht auf mich, geht keiner wirklich drauf
Wo ist das weg?
Fuck, ich hätte ihn heilen sollen
Die haben nur Winter, oder? Irgendwas hat mich gesniped von hinten oder fast gesniped
Der hat nicht mal viel, der Genji
Was, das hat er überlebt, da, fuck
Genji ist wieder da
Nice
Ich spamm mal Schild
Orissa-Attack sackt halt auch mal richtig
Ich bin down
Tschau, ich bin down
Ich hab aber gleich Ulti
Ich hab gleich Ulti, 5%
Oh, huge res, huge res
Wir gehen da gleich mit Ulti rein
So, ich mach noch einen Kill, dann gehen wir mit Ulti rein
Komm Genji, geh rein, geh rein
Gengu, go go, movet euch
Oh, oh, ich hab Mccree gehört, ich hab Mccree-Ulten gehört
Huge
Diana, Ana ist fast down
Genji auch fast tot
Bleibt eigentlich Ulti, Mercy
Oh, wie ich ihn nicht treffe
Krasses Endplace
Ich greife mal ein bisschen Heal
Charge ab
Wir müssen auf die Minicraft aufpassen
Oh, Winston, Winston, Alter
Komm zurück
Ich hab gleich wieder Ulti
Geht übelst ab
Wieder Ulti am Start
Ich push weiter, ich push mit der Orissa, es sind sonst zu wenig dran
Falls ich vorkommen soll, sag, oder wenn ihr gevibe bleibt, ich kann Ulten
Sag bloß rechtzeitig Bescheid
Wir sind gleich durch
Ich muss wieder ein bisschen üben
Oh, es ist keiner am Paylord
Ich bin dran
Fuck, bisschen, bisschen zu spät
Mccree
Du hast, du hast Norb drauf
Du hast Discord
Nice
Achievement unlocked
Mach den Reinhard kaputt
Oh oh
Weg, weg, Dorino
Huge, der hat Shatter
Der hat mich schon so
Der Shattert mich, mit seinen Augen Shattert er mich schon
Mach Blatt
Komm her, Reinhard
Weiter haben wir verloren
Direkt
60% Ult
Nice
Pressen mega Damage
Ich könnte Ulten
Mercy, Huge Rest
Nein, kein Huge Rest
Es war das Gegenteil von Huge Rest
Aber es war nice, das Stand Place
Ist auch übelst geil
Eines war mein Lieblings Supporter oder generell mein Lieblings Helm
Kannste die Gegner so recken
Mccree machen oder, komm wir warten mal was die picken
Moin, Matti
Akamu
Einfach Pix
Dovengi, ja habe ich
Hey Max hast du auch ein Nahrungsmittel, das du als Kind gar nicht mochtest und jetzt überdurchschnittlich magst?
Rote Beete
Huge Other Place
Rote Beete fand ich eklig, meine Oma hat das immer gemacht wie ich klein war
Genau so die Oma hat auch zu Sylvester glaube ich war das oder was weiter
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich habe immer irgendwie Zunge von irgendeinem Viech gemacht
Der ist auch übelst eklig, mittlerweile schmeckt es mir
Moment kurz, ich muss mich kurz mehr muten
Einer hat an der Tür geklopft, traut sich aber nicht rein zu kommen
Jetzt werden sie gereckt
Ich verstecke mich schon ein bisschen falls sie da rumschneidern
Ich dachte gerade ich hatte schon Angst
Der McCree ist fast tot
Was schießt denn der Junker eigentlich hin?
Der macht keinen einzigen Hitmarker
Ich schliebe dich Saria, du wirst jetzt gesliebt
Tracer links, Tracer linke Seite
Auf mir drauf, irgendwas von hinten
Ich weiß nicht was, McCree
Das war One Clip
Die hat mich One Clipped
One Clip
Da kommt schon McCree
Das liebt, das liebt, das liebt, das liebt
Ich innate den
Tyrannosaurus reckt
Lordhawk du bist viel zu weit vorne
Tracer ist rechts in der Bibliothek drin
Jetzt können wir pushen
Das liebt, das liebt, das liebt
Hat sich ausgesliebt
Die können eigentlich voll gut pushen jetzt
Will aber keiner
Genji ist auch drin
Oh fuck
Verpisst dich Harambe
Never forget
Sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep, sleep
Tracer hinter euch
Oh oh, ich stehe da ganz schön kacke drin
Schön die Lane Zeit holen
Muss sein, die Zeit ist noch zu gut
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall nochmal contesten jetzt
Ich wundere das, wir haben eigentlich die übelste Spam Combo
Aber wir haben keinen Damage
Ist schwierig, ja ja
Und wir pushen auch nicht, wenn wir pushen können
Wir hätten die zweimal super vipeen können
So Leute, rein jetzt da
Wir haben Schild
Auf Orisa
Wenn wir Nano boost nicht am besten
Rechts, rechts die Tracer
Komm ich Nano boost jetzt die Orisa
Irgendwas
Jetzt wie beim Junk machen so
Muss weg
Ist der tot, der McCree?
Ja, okay
Purple
Dass wir hier nicht back capped werden
Oh Achtung, da ist ein Fahrrad in der Mitte
Da sollten wir jetzt nicht hin
Das recommande ich auch Orisa
Leute, ist der Game Sound okay oder zu leise?
Links Tracer neben mir
Ich hab keine Granate da
Ich bin heal auf dir
Das weiß ich ja nie
Die will rechts flanken
Ich hab eine Rakete abgegeben
Nice, huge res
Schleft
Fahrer, Fahrer von hinten irgendwo
Über uns
Noch eine Tracer
Nice
Das haben wir schön gestalt jetzt
Gleich wieder Nano boost
Leider etwas leise, ich mach Game Sound
Kann ich nach der Runde lauter machen
Ticken
Wenn ihr wollt, kann ich nach der Runde machen
Roadhog, übertreib es nicht
Ich dachte er hat Ulti und kann die wegspammen
Ja kann er doch, mach doch Roadhog
Nein
Aber Zeit ist top
Mit Kopfhörer ist das auch perfekt
Da kann ich es auch so lassen
Kriegen wir es nochmal? Nein
Er hat immer noch einen hitscan
Der Ae scannt
Ins Gesicht fliegen
Und scannen
Dann ist das auch hitscan beim Champion
Area scan
Ich versuche eine Granate hinterher zu hauen
So knapp
Junk, ich will dich heilen
Kannst ja mal probieren
Ich muss nachladen
Auf die Fahrer müssen wir achten
Ich sehe den Genji nicht
Gengu
Rechts
Soldier wie sie aussieht jetzt
Vielleicht sollten wir nicht ganz so übertrieben weit vorne halten
Es sind noch 35 Sekunden
Soldier bei mir hinten
Die werden aber geregt ey
Er will auf mich
Ich hab Schiss
Was? Moment
Chat warum hat mich die Granate nicht geheilt
Ich hab eine Granate auf meine Füße geworfen die es gemacht hat
Please explain
Warum hat mich das nicht geheilt gerade
Die kann durch den Spalt
Da ist ein Spalt in der Erde
WTF
Das ist so ein Spalt wenn man ihn treffen will trifft man ihn nicht
Dann wirft man aus Versehen rein
Ah gut
Bist du aufgewärmt
Jetzt kannst du ja dazu eintragen
Gehen wir kurz aufs Klo und so weiter
Ist gleich alles schön geklippt
Jetzt muss ich mir das mal angucken
Und dann wartet mal wir gucken uns das jetzt mal kurz zusammen auf Offstream an
Display Capture
Das nervt mich in OBS immer ein bisschen
Jetzt gucken wir mal
Alter
Nee oder
Ich hab Schiss
Ich glaub's net
Was
Chat warum hat mich die Granate nicht
Ja gut
Shit Happens
Ist ein Duo Partner ein Real Life Kollege oder hast du ihn im Internet kennen gelernt
Er ist ein ehemaliges Overwatch Teammate aus unserer ganz am Anfang von Overwatch aus unserem 6 Deck
Wo wir auch ein paar Cups mit gespielt haben
Und eigentlich ganz gut dabei waren
Der Th auch der vorhin im Chat war
Und wir haben uns gedacht es ist mal wieder Zeit Overwatch raus zu holen
Nachdem es ihn übelst getiltet hat solo zu spielen und mich haben wir gedacht komm wir du killen jetzt einfach ordentlich
Und seitdem macht es auch wieder viel mehr Spaß das kann ich auch nur jedem empfehlen jeden den das anpisst
Solo zu spielen Duo ist gleich mal eine ganze Ecke entspannter
Die ganzen New Zeichen bei der Helden Galerie Triggern ich hab in der Helden Galerie noch nichts eingestellt
Noch gar nichts wir machen jetzt Lootbox auf
Nichts Goldes
Jetzt was Goldes irgendwas irgendwas Goldes für irgendeinen Held den ich spiele
Hä
Spiele ich nicht Spiele ich nicht Spiele ich nicht aber ok Währung ist nicht schlecht
Wollen wir holen wir uns garantiert nicht
Roadhog
Aber die coolen Skins kosten halt mehr ne
Was gibt es denn was gibt es denn für Reinhard Skins
Die nicht so viel kosten
1000 1000
Der ist nice
Ne Bundeswehr Bundeswehr wird unlocked Bundeswehr Reinhard
Hab ich ein ordentlichen Skin dran
Kusswort fragen planst du wieder ein 6er Team zusammen zu stellen
Wenn man sich jetzt überlegt von welchem Kaliber die Themes aktuell sind
Um da auch nur halbwegs wieder dran zu kommen erstens traue ich mir das selbst nicht zu mittlerweile
Da wieder wirklich mitzuspielen und du müsstest ja quasi noch noch weitere Leute finden
Und dann müsstest du jeden Tag oder spielst du jeden zweiten Tag 5-6 Stunden triten und üben
Da hab ich keine Zeit für
Ich spiele das ganze casual mäßig
Das reicht mir
Bisschen Duo Queue Ranks und wenn sie das Rankingsystem verbessern umso besser
Und wenn es irgendwann mal eine Team Queue geben sollte
Also irgendwas wo man dann auch wirklich gegen andere Teams auf ähnlichem Rank spielt
Dann kann man sich das wieder überlegen
Es ist wie gesagt ich hab es in jedem Stream glaube ich gesagt jetzt
Dass ich irgendwie ein bisschen absurd finde dass es gerade in Overwatch wo auch der Hersteller selbst sagt
Das ist ein Team Spiel dass es eben keine Team Queue gibt
Ich verstehe das nicht warum
Warum gibt es keine Team Queue
Jo hab eine Smurf auf Master kann ich mit Queue
Ne grad nicht wir bleiben erst mal Duo
Ja ich Queue
MrFryger mehr Lootboxen soll ich mehr Lootboxen aufmachen
Wollt ihr mehr Lootboxen
Erinnert euch das dann nicht so sehr an Battlefront oder sowas
Wenn ihr wollt kann ich nächste nach der Runde alle Lootboxen auf
Was ist Gifts im Menü
Kartoffel 209 Gifts im Menü kannst du dir Hardstar und Kartenpacks kaufen
Warum auch immer man das in Overwatch machen sollte keine Ahnung ich weiß es nicht
Ich hör mal was die anderen picken
Uni Smurf
Wirklich bestimmt Genji Main
Natürlich kann ja nicht anders sein
Ja 7 Stunden
Uni Smurf
Wenn der Genji Main ist da können wir mindestens grillen
Gucken wir mal
Moment was ist denn das
Haben wir wieder so einen geilen Symmetra Thrower im Team
Wir müssen glaube ich irgendwann mal noch einen Torb und Symmetra Main Counter machen
Im Stream
Hat geswitcht okay
Max was hältst du von Battlefront 2
Ich nichts
Der Eax hat es ein bisschen gespielt du fand es ganz gut
Ja wenn man die Tilt Sachen auslässt
Sowas hatte ich bei Battlefront 2 getiltet
Ja ratte mal
Die Helden
Die Lootbox
Ja
Komplette Charakter anlocken du brauchst Joykappen das musst du ignorieren dann macht das Spiel Spaß
Ich weiß gar nicht ob es mittlerweile wieder drinnen ist
Oh hier ist ein Turret
Kannst du hoch gehen oben ist ein Turret
Wo oben
Über dir
Da
Der Genji hat ordentlich Damage gefressen
Ich geh da gleich rein sobald ich wieder Heal habe
Oh fuck fuck fuck ich krieg Damage
Ich hatte die Auswahl zwischen Torb, Shotgun und Turret
Ja das war kacke
Ich hätte nicht auf den Spot gesollt sondern dem Genji hinterher
Aber wenn wir schnell sind
Nice nice pick nice pick
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Aber wir sind schneller wieder da
Ich bin schlechter Winston
Leute lasst euch nicht picken
Lasst euch nicht picken
Gebt dem keinen Charger nichts einfach wieder rein jetzt
Ich brauche Hilfe
Ich bin down
Der Torb ist hinten rechts drinnen
Nice picks ultra nice picks
Ich bleibe jetzt noch auf Winston und haue Ult raus
Auf den nächsten Punkten wenn das nicht funktioniert
Dann würde ich schon noch ein bisschen üben
Die kommen wieder
Oh ich bin gesleebt
Warum sind die eigentlich alle wieder da gerade?
Wie sind die so schnell wieder hergekommen?
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Die waren auf einmal wieder da
Das geht eigentlich gar nicht so schnell
So ich bleibe noch mal
Den Attack bleibe ich noch mal Winston
Warum zum Teufel hast du den Account Huplos?
Der ursprünglich kein Fake Account, sondern ein Undercover Account gewesen ist
Okay, go go
Ich bin auf dem Punkt
Unten rechts ist die Sombra
Gleich kommt eine Sombra auf den Punkt
Ich sehe sie bloß nicht
So kann es auch gehen
Trinkst du eigentlich Energydrinks?
Oder hältst du nicht so viel davon?
Ich trinke keine Energydrinks
Aber ich halte auch jetzt nicht weder viel noch wenig von
Das soll jeder trinken wenn ihm das irgendwie was hilft
Ich trinke aber auch kein Kaffee oder ganz selten Kaffee
Ich würde fast, die spielen 100% wieder Genji
100%
Das sind nämlich beide die Typen, die da
Dieser KFC und da ohne es beides Genjimains
Oder soll ich zweitens was?
Was spielt dieser Warts?
Oh wir haben zwei Mercy Mains
Wir haben zwei Mercy Mains
Wartsit und Crystal
Wo sind die Mercy Mains?
Wo sind die Mercy Mains wenn man sie braucht?
Jetzt haben wir sie doppelt
Moin Plops
Tracer
Der wird wahrscheinlich gelivet
Hast du gesehen bei denen?
Nee ich hörs klar schon
Ja dann spielen die Tracer Genji
Die anderen spielen definitiv Genji
Ist links durch
Ach komm ey
Der McCree soll mal den Panzer abschießen
Schild ist kaputt
Ich block das Tor ihr müsst hier hinten plat machen
Habt ihr's geplant? Schild ist wieder kaputt
Hanzo Hanzo ist da
Ich brauch heal
Ich verpiss mich mal und lad Schild
Tja
Oh Sen perfektes Timing
Gerade weil ich verreckt bin
Ich bin so weit vom Earthshatter weg
Was könnte ich denn gegen die gescheit picken?
Ich hab das Gefühl mit Reinhard geht da nicht so viel
Weil die nicht so Gespamme am Start haben
Nimm mal Winston
Hanzo
Wer ist das Soldier?
Hallo Shagger
Linke Seite
Soldier ist tot
Hanzo ist rechts in der Tür
Reinhard kommt hoch
Sie sagen erst noch unten das passt
Die hat nicht mehr viel
Die können doch eh
Soldier in der Mitte solo
Geh mal auf den Soldier in der Mitte
Jo
Ich bin halt relativ low
Ich bleib auf dem Spot stehen
Die Anna hat nicht mehr viel
Ich bin auf dem Spot
Soldier haut ab
Soldier ist abgehauen
Oben der Hanzo
Hanzo
Pass auf Sen
Siehst du die Anna unten?
Ich bin links in der Öffnung
Ja
Ich seh sie unter uns
Die kommen hoch
Reinhard ist ziemlich isoliert unten
Ich hab den Soldier
Hanzo
Der Soldier ist runtergenockt
Er macht erst mal nichts mehr
Reinhard oben
So, down
Soldier steht Main
Den können wir chasen
Na
Den können wir nicht
Zu viele
Hätten wir können
Soldier links
Ich schlafe
Ich bin geschlitzt
Der Genji ist nach oben
Und der Soldier
Geht auf den Punkt
Nice pick
Ich bin auf dem Punkt
Sonst keiner da
Ich bin zu dumm zum springen
Ich bin über denen
Wenn sie unten reinkommen sollten
Sag mal, ob du siehst
Oder nicht
Wo ist der Gengu?
Ich bin geschlitzt
Fuck
Ah, ich bin wieder da
Ich hab wie Schmerz die Hasse
Kackheld er
Reudiger Kackheld
Zurück
Tracer
Rechts Sider
Ist irgendwas auf der linken Seite
Irgendwas solo
McCree ist da
Und Rortoc, die kommen jetzt rein
Ich brauch noch 4 bis Schild
Oh, oh, oh, ich bin geflasht
Fuck
Jetzt haben sie mich gerapt
Die Mercy steht direkt neben euch
Oh, huge res
Sniper, Sniper, auf der anderen Seite
Auch gut
Nicht los hier im Chat, oder wie?
Die sind alle so gefesselt vom Gameplay-Checker
Bei krassen Wilson-Plays
Wo sind sie denn?
Ich lauf dir nicht hinterher McCree
Easy Win
Was hältst du von Sombra in ranked auf ganz speziellen Punkten?
Gut
Also man kann sie zum Beispiel auf Volskaya oder so Defans einsetzen
Wenn du coole Sombra-Plays sehen willst, kannst du dir auf Twitch den Stream von Chipshine angucken
Oder die Sombra-Games, die es in Overwatch-League gab, Dallas Fuel gegen das letzte Dallas Fuel-Game
Die haben wir ganz schön gereckt, würde ich sagen
Ich muss kurz aufs Klo
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Ja, ich komm auch kurz 2 Minuten weg
2 Minuten
So, gleich wieder da
So
Wieder am Start
Hab ich irgendwas überlesen im Chat?
Aber ich hab's angekündigt heute
Winning Stream 3-0
Eats
So, aber wirklich verhältnismäßig wenig im Chat los
Sicherlich alle so geschafft
Wer mir noch nicht voll laut auf Twitch kann das natürlich gerne machen
Und ihr könnt auch mal auf YouTube vorbeigucken und natürlich auch auf Twitter
Muss ja mal ein bisschen sehr laut machen ab und zu
Falls mich jemand nicht von YouTube kennt, das ist eigentlich so die Plattform, wo ich ursprünglich herkomme
Gibt's seit 2010 Videos zu aktuellen Themen aus dem Gaming-Bereich und so alles drum herum
Über, glaub, 800 Videos mittlerweile
Also ist schon ein bisschen was
Ist genug Content da, ist bestimmt auch das ein oder andere für euch dabei
Ein Milchmensch fragt, hast du noch dein Pro-Klo?
Klar hab ich das noch
Das war ja auch teuer
Das war ja auch teuer das Klo, warum sollte ich das wegschmeißen?
Sag mal, wenn du ready bist
Ist ready? Auf geht's
Mach mal wieder ein Gartenvideo
HeroLP hast du mal vor zwei Tagen auf den Channel geguckt
Oh, wir haben Kami fast eingeholt
Also ich glaub ich hab ihn überholt mittlerweile
Was ist denn das?
Brunnen
Wie geht das?
Ich glaub, ich guck mal ob wir schöne Mercy-Mains
Ja, Nicely
Nicelyli
Nicelyli hat das Mercy-Main
Mit 20 Stunden
Bäm
Winrate 54
Easy, easy carry
Käfer was das für eine verscheuerte Frage
Zeig mal her, was haben wir denn hier eigentlich jetzt für eine
Das geht
Orissa ist hier cool, wenn man das drauf hat mit diesem Minicraft, kann es Leute in Brunnen ziehen
Team voice please
Ja komm, bevor er tiltet, ich geh mal Team voice, dann freut er sich
HeroLP, ich hab ein Gartenvideo, sag ich doch
Check, krieg mich durch
Oh, oh, oh
Mein Güte, treff mal was wirkst, treff was
Anna ist fast down, ah fuck, aber auch nur fast.
Ich hänge drinnen.
Ich bin raus, ich bin raus.
Was?!
Oh, der Lucio, nice play.
Was muss man sagen?
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren, das hat er gut gemacht.
Moina, du solltest vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt...
...die Sachen ja one on one.
Gleich wieder da.
Fuck.
Genji ist down.
Das Dimmste, was dir passieren kann, ist, wenn deine Teammates auf der rechten Seite stehen...
...weil die Gegner auch rechts stehen und du hast als Widowmaker dann keinen Gangwunder.
Wer hat dich gekillt? Der Genji, ne?
Genji ist hochge...
...geflitzt.
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
Fünf Prozent.
Ok, wir wollen anscheinend hier durch.
Nice.
Lucio ist weg.
Die Anna will nicht bestimmt sleepen.
Sollte sie aber.
Da geht er down.
Der gute Scientist.
Genji links?
Ich glaub, der will zu dir.
Fuck, was war denn das für ein Sprung?
Genji ist am Helzberg rechts.
Boah.
Jetzt wollte es aber echt wissen.
Nice, nice, doll.
Jetzt kann man regroupen.
Ulti hätt ich besser setzen können.
Nein!
Hast du dich selbst erschossen?
Ja.
Wir sind halt einer down. Eigentlich sollten wir jetzt noch gar nicht pushen.
Ja, oder die Mercy hätte gerast. Alter, das...
Ich werd jetzt vorne gehandelt.
Boah, ich hab die richtig schön gefiel in die Saria jetzt.
So wie macht's nicht mal.
Nice, nice pick. Go, go.
Ich bin mir beim Crosshair voll drauf, aber es trifft nicht.
Genji ist fast down.
Ist wieder auf dem Weg. Aus dem Weg.
Nein!
Fuck.
Saria ist fast tot.
Hä? Boah, sie hat getroffen. Lul, Alter.
Auto wieder am Start.
Nein, das war fail. Oh, war das schlecht. Oh Gott, war das schlecht.
Das hab ich so verkackt, ey.
Das hab ich richtig verkackt.
Ich hätte auf die andere Seite fliegen müssen, dann die Bombe reinsetzen.
Nicht so eine Kacke.
900 IQ, ult, ja.
Warum haben wir das überhaupt verloren?
Also wir haben eigentlich schon alle Blatt gehabt. Oh, das war schlecht.
Seid ihr in der Craft verreckt?
Ich nicht, aber die Leute.
Ah, hätte ich den Genji gekillt, der war so low.
Ja, super.
Die waren gerade nichts anderes, außer um die zu handeln.
Ich muss was anderes nehmen als D.Va, das klappt nicht.
Jetzt soll ich tiefer bleiben.
Ich fühle mich nicht effektiv als D.Va gerade.
Vor allem gegen die Saria.
Ja guck, der Roger dürfte auch nicht so effektiv sein.
Ich vergesse mal, wir haben zwei Pix.
Drei Pix.
Rauf auf den Kackepunkt.
Hopp, rein da.
Oh, oh, oh.
Dann kann man den nicht durch Gegner durchblinken.
Rutsch.
Wo ist die Ana von denen?
Ana hinten, solo für Spots.
Voll in die Saria reingehauen.
Okay, komm jetzt.
Ein Fight gewinnen und gut ist.
Nee, ich bin in Roadhog glaube ich auch nicht so gut gegen die.
Mal gucken, dass ich nicht die Saria immer die ganze Zeit anschieße.
Was ich ja mache.
Regroup.
Weiter regroup einfach.
Ich werde die ganze Zeit von Unsichtwarenwänden aufgehalten.
Die ganze Zeit.
Soldier haben wir.
Tracer ist noch am Start.
Komm noch mal.
Also Leute, die Runde ist echt keine Klanzleistung.
Zumindest nicht von mir.
Du machst das ja gut.
Ohne dich hätte man das in der Hand gewonnen.
Ich habe jetzt wieder das Problem, was ich am Anfang auch hatte, als wir angefangen haben.
Da ich voll überfordert bin, so wieder, was machst du jetzt, was machst du jetzt, was machst du jetzt?
So, Sniper-Time.
Das stimmt gerade eh was nicht. Ich habe zweimal geblinkt und zweimal gegen mir Unsichtwarenwand gekracht.
Ich habe es gesehen rechts beim Helzpack.
Einmal Hingste.
Die Tracer ist hinter uns.
Die Ana-Counter-Swipe. Ich werde schildrig da umgehen.
Mercy ist weg.
Alter!
Wo sind denn alle?
Fuck! Ich wusste gar nicht, dass alle tot sind. Sonst hätte ich mich schneller geweilt.
Rechte Seite, rechte.
Das wird fix schmecken.
Wir machen da gefüllt gut Damage.
Ich habe jetzt Ulti.
Also vom Damage her geht nichts.
Also willst du nicht für mein Gefühl ganz gut Damage?
So, jetzt mit Ulti rein nochmal.
Jetzt muss ich jetzt. Huge Ult muss jetzt.
Tracer fickt uns.
Wo ist die Tracer?
Ich höre links irgendwas.
Ja, links. Tracer hat das sich.
Oder rechts jetzt? Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe das geflasht.
Ich bin auf dem Punkt.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
Das ist eigentlich für komische Spawn-Karte.
Okay, wir sind wieder da.
Ich höre links irgendwas. Der Reinhold ist wieder da.
Die muss weg.
Alter, nice gecarried.
Das war echt nichts.
Ich komme gerade auch nicht klar.
Das war ja grausam.
Nicht im Teamchat.
Huge Rats.
Das müsste funktionieren, sonst habe ich den Nightbot kaputt gemacht.
Probier mal Sens. Habe ich gestern hinzugefügt.
Funktioniert.
Objektivzeit.
3600.
Aber heute Winning Stream angekündigt und schon Winning Stream.
Das ist eine psychologische Sache.
Wenn man Losing Stream ankündigt, lust du wahrscheinlich.
Du musst da taktisch rangehen.
Ich habe gestern oder so Exkursive geguckt,
da hat auch Fat Winning Climbing Stream im Titel stehen gehabt.
Da war dann ein paar Stunden nachdem er angefangen hat 07.
Da war halt die Krippe.
Können wir kurz Pause machen?
Wieso, passt du?
Nein.
Alter meine Katze stinkt.
Wie darf ich das jetzt verstehen?
Und vor allem, warum gehst du auf Twitch und ist im Chat mitzuteilen?
Was steckt da dahinter?
Ja.
Justus, genau so ist es.
Alle schreiben so immer Voice Chat, Team Voice, sonst was.
Und dann kommt nix oder Geflamer.
So, Passwurm TS Richtung Oldschool mit Turbo Icon.
Jokzokz, Jokzokz, komm jetzt.
Speed, heute noch gar nicht los Jokz spielt.
Wir sind Defens.
WTF?
Oder ich mach 2. Support geht auch. Gucken wir mal.
Komm, ja ich spiel trotzdem mal Lucian.
Ich bock drauf.
So eine gute Kompromisse aus Nerven und sogar ganz gut heilen.
Wie lange bleibst du bis gestern on?
Nachts ist kälter als draußen. Oder was? Was ist das für ein Satz?
Ich war hier noch nie draußen.
Stirbt man da, wenn man rausgeht? Oder ist da irgendwie, wo man aufpassen muss?
Weil ich will jetzt nicht weiten.
Nee, man fliegt.
Man fliegt.
Die haben auch gedacht, hey, wenn wir jetzt eine Map auf Mond haben, da müssen wir so Gravitationsspiele reinbauen.
Aber ihnen ist wahrscheinlich ums Verrecken nichts eingefallen, wie man das ins Gameplay integrieren könnte.
Dann haben sie es außen gemacht.
Bestimmt wird auch. Bestimmt wird auch.
Bestimmt irgendwas schneiden.
Fahrer? Okay.
Oh, und Schneiber.
Okay.
Unten links, Soldier.
Unten D.Va.
Nein, mach den Soldier weg.
Ja Mercy, du solltest da vielleicht nicht alleine.
Soll ich dich abholen? Ich kann dich abholen, die sind alle tot.
Die Sombra, passt das hier?
Die müssen uns einfach nur verzögern.
Wo ist der Schneiber?
Nein, nein, nein.
Hier, nimm das Ding.
Ah nee, ist gehackst, gehacksort.
Ist von uns gehacksort, von uns gehacksort.
Wir müssen zum Spot.
Kack, Doomfist.
Reinhardt, mach doch dein Schild mal vorne hin.
Wo ist der Sniper?
Keine Ahnung.
Wir müssen auf uns spawnen.
Soldier, Soldier, Soldier.
Ich bin bei dir.
Soldier hinter dir.
Wieder oben rechts, oben rechts.
Beziehungsweise von dir oben links.
Im Technikraum da.
Callouts Overwatch, null.
Gleich Ulti, gleich Ulti.
Pass auf, pass auf, nicht...
Wenn die reinkommen, wird geultet.
Ich muss warten, da ich nicht zu früh ulte.
Soldier ist oben rechts.
Ich hab Speed an.
Mercy, Murky.
Oh fuck.
Sag mir, wenn du gespawned bist.
Nee, nee, nee.
Ich kann dir nicht helfen kommen.
Leute, wo seid ihr denn?
Leute, wo seid ihr denn? Alter, wo seid ihr denn alle?
Die Iris.
Oh, das ist ein...
Geballt.
Ich find schade, dass die Leute mittlerweile so passiv geworden sind.
Weile Schiss, keiner drauf.
So ein richtiges, weiß nicht, Baby-Gameplay geworden.
Da muss gefistet werden.
Auch ohne Doomfist.
Oh, Doomfist, verpiss dich, Alter.
Doomfist ist noch oben drinne.
Hinter mir, hinter mir.
Alter, Doomfist.
Dieser Dreckschar, der ist hinter dem LKW links.
Man kann das blocken mit dem Schild.
Ich kann das.
Ich komm fort zum Healsorn.
Komm zurück, komm zurück.
Um links ist wieder was.
What the fuck, meine Schüsse gingen einfach durch.
Was soll denn das?
Doomfist ist kacke.
Wir müssen jetzt nicht, wir können jetzt nicht schießen.
Wir müssen jetzt nicht, wir dürfen jetzt nicht sterben.
Weil die können nicht weiterpushen, wenn wir am Leben bleiben.
Ich bin bei dir.
Ey, dieser Dreckschar.
Doomfist, lull.
Wir sollten ein bisschen safe stehen.
Ich bin hier gerade voll im Sichtfeld.
Hauptsache mal Hupe ins Nichts.
Alter, komm, komm, komm.
Wo landet es?
Ich bin bei dir, den holen wir.
Reckt, Doomfist, reckt.
Keine Ulti mehr.
Pass auf, pass auf.
Doomfist.
Er hat gegen die Wand gefestet.
So wirklich koordiniert ist es auch nicht hier.
Wow.
Lull.
Das war Max Range Hook auf Doom.
Okay, Ulti 20%.
Wir müssen jetzt irgendwie voll bekommen.
Alter, der verfickte Dreckshorthock, der geht mir immer so was auf den Piss.
Der hat dich gekillt, als er gestunnt war.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Mega Kakres.
Wir haben Picks, wir haben Picks.
Ich muss ordentlich contesten.
Geht das?
Ich muss halt nur jemanden contesten, der DPS ist.
Ich geh drauf.
Ich hab gleich.
Okay, nice.
Ich bleib drauf.
Mein Gott.
Boob ihn doch weg, du bist gestunt, nachdem du gehooked wirst.
Also wenn du gehooked wirst und One-Shotted wirst, kannst du nichts machen.
Es sei denn, er killt dich nicht One-Shot und erst, also ne, danach kannst du boopen.
Oder eh überhaupt irgendwas machen.
Oder Shiften als Moira, oder Raceform als Reaper, oder was auch immer.
Wenn er dich One-Shotted, dann hast du gelippt.
Schalana-Skeletten.
Hat von euch jemand zufällig ein Aquarium und kann mir weiterhelfen?
Ich glaube, das ist hier der optimale Chat für alle Fischfreunde.
Hier ganz bestimmt, ganz viele.
Aber ich kann ihr leider nicht helfen mit deinem Aquarium.
Ja, Shaggy in Silber klappt das meist, weil die Leute zu doof sind zu aimen und zu One-Hitten.
Es ist aber schwierig aktuell mit Water consistent zu One-Hitten.
Also die meisten Targets, die meisten bisschen dickeren Low HP Targets kriegst du mit Hook, Schuss, Melee.
Kaputt, aber auch nicht so richtig consistent.
Ich spreche Nahkampf-Melee aus.
So wie Meel.
Weißt du, was man das nicht so ausspricht?
Was?
Who cares?
Melee.
Könnte man ja auch sagen.
Nein, kein Headshot.
Ja Leute, es kommt keiner, es kommt keiner.
Ja das dachte ich auch, es kommt aber keiner.
Der Doomfist will Fist.
Das war ja mal der lächerlichste Angriff aller Zeiten.
Melee, Melee.
Ich bin für Melee.
Melee ist beste.
Wenn ich mit Fabian bin, bin ich beeinigt.
Das heißt Melee.
Nice, wir haben Pick.
Leute, Move!
Move!
Ich kriege Anfälle.
Warum moveen wir da nicht?
Ich kriege übelste Anfälle.
Das regt mich auch gerade auf.
Wir haben sogar ordentliche Picks.
Was?
Oh Gott.
Okay, okay.
Also wenn die jetzt nicht reingehen, dann kotze ich.
Ich gehe jetzt rein.
Egal ob die reingehen, ich gehe jetzt rein.
Easy, Speedboost.
Ration.
Easy win.
Tracer, slow.
So, so, so.
Melee.
Haben wir Melee oder haben wir die Tracer?
Warum testen die das so spät noch?
Wir können jetzt direkt durchgehen.
Oh fuck.
Doomfist, verpiss dich du Drecksheld.
Alter Doomfist.
Okay Ulti ist raus, meine Ulti ist gleich da.
Okay.
Jawoll, Pick, Pick, Pick. Wo ist die Tracer?
Speed.
Mercy ist low, Mercy ist low hinten.
Das war kacke, der hat mich weggefistet.
Meteor Strike.
Übrigens mein Felder, den ich bei Mccree rausgeboopt habe.
Ich kann jetzt was machen.
Ich kann jetzt was bauen gehen.
Heck.
Wir müssen das haben.
Nein, ich wollte da hin.
Piss dich Showtalk.
Erzähl.
Der Beat vor ihm.
Lucio springt hoch, wird gefistet beim springen und fliegt 5 Meter nach hinten und trifft nur das halbe Team.
WP Lucio.
Okay.
Ich hab's gerissen, offensichtlich.
Auch wenn mir das nicht so bewusst war.
Wahnsinn, ey.
Ich dachte diese halb AFK Torbjorn Plays werden gefixt.
Das war gut für uns.
Wenn sowas Play of the Game ist, dann haben die sonst nicht viel auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Sauber, guck mal wie viel es jetzt gegeben hat.
Das hat auch mal mein Fünfer Hatchet durch überschrieben.
Ja, das sagt er.
Nimmst du auf gerade?
Äh, nein.
Gar nicht viel.
20 Punkte.
Das wäre gerade nicht laufen.
Leute, habe ich das Game davor schon eingetragen?
Als Win?
Ja, ne? Wir sind jetzt bei 5-0.
Easy.
Next?
Jojo.
Wie viel bist du eigentlich schon?
Alter!
Na gut, einmal minus 50 Telekom, ne?
Ja, aber trotzdem hab ich dich schon...
Danke. Danke Telekom.
Das sind ja schon über 100 Punkte Abstand.
Ja.
Du musst überlegen, ich war ja 100 niedriger als du.
Du warst niedriger, ja.
Schreckt.
Ist ja noch Performance-Based.
Das heißt, du performen... Du performenst einfach.
Ja.
Was du ja auch machst, ist es ja nicht.
Bei reinen Win-Loss...
Hättest du es nicht gegeben.
Aber gestern an der Runde, wo...
Mit Reaper, Lúcio, hat man richtig gesehen,
dass einfach Performance-Based nicht funktioniert in dem Game.
Moin, Little Samsung.
Top 500, Inca. Das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Das dauert noch.
Torpion-Skill-Cam.
Jo.
Du kannst ja noch mal Speed spielen.
Garten.
Probieren wir es mal.
Na, wie läuft's? Läuft gut.
Krass, wo wird auf Lays kommen jetzt?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das Heiler-Team aus...
Soll ich...
Ich mache hier.
Mercy-Main.
Dass das andere Prima-Team sich nicht dazu bewegen möchte,
hier einen Tank auszupacken.
Nein, das ist der Wahnsinn.
Oh.
Overrated.
Wir machen jetzt unsere besten Stats, hier.
Damage Boost.
Ist Zen eigentlich noch nicht spielbar?
Ja, Zen ist zur Zeit
so der zweite Meta-Support.
Nebar, Mercy
Nein, zweiter Schuss, fuck
Zweiter Schuss verfehlt
Ich muss mal heilen
Mercy low
Loll
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung
Mercy, du musst mal heilen
Genji hüpft hinter uns
Ich nehme ein, es ist außer mir sonst keiner da
Äh, HÄÄH
Es ist gar keiner raus
Ach doch, es ist er wieder raus, der ist raus und wieder rein, das hab ich das
Das ist so erbärmlich, eine Minute mitten im Game.
Das ist so lächerlich.
So.
6-0.
Easy.
Das zähle ich jetzt einfach als Win.
Fertig.
Kein Bock.
Ich queue, äh, kann ich queueen?
Oder willst du kurz Pause machen?
Äh, kurz Pause.
Okay.
Das zähle ich jetzt, Leute, ich zähle das als Win.
Das sehe ich nicht aus.
Zumindest, wenn es schon nicht in-Game als Win zählt,
dann können wir es wir wenigstens als Win zählen.
Eats Win, Eats Live.
So sieht es aus.
Oh, bis gleich.
Bis gleich.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum das immer noch als Win zählt,
aber es ist so.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es sogar in der Beta schon so war.
Ich glaube, das war sogar in der Beta schon so.
Das war, glaube ich, in der Beta schon so.
Ich kann mich da nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Aber ich glaube, da gab es schon Posts,
wo sich die Leute darüber aufgeregt haben,
wie kann das sein, nachdem quasi schon...
Das ist ja auch so auf Numbani zum Beispiel, ja?
Wenn du da den ersten Punkt schnell verlierst,
sagt dann irgendwie, oh, nö, ich liege nicht.
Das ist ja auch so auf Numbani zum Beispiel, ja?
Sagt dann irgendwie, oh, nö, ich leave und join wieder rein.
Ich werde euch jetzt nicht erklären, wie das funktioniert,
weil einfach mit leaven und join ist es nicht getan.
Aber das ist lächerlich.
Schon den Zen-Buff auf dem PTR gesehen.
Was ich gesehen habe, ist, dass Zen jetzt so einen,
können wir uns ja mal zusammen angucken,
so eine Anzeige hat, ob Targets, wie viel Leben die haben.
Meinst du das?
Können wir uns mal zusammen angucken, finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Moment.
Zeig es euch.
OBS Display Capture.
Hier, guck, da sieht man Zenyatta Harmony Orb.
Da, guck.
Das ist jetzt neu bei Zen auf dem PTR.
Und wenn er Discord Orb drauf macht...
Discord Orb?
Moment, wie heißt er?
Wie heißt denn der Orb noch mal?
Harmony Orb und?
Heißt das nicht Discord?
Jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt.
Wie der Damage Orb heißt.
Discord, ja.
Ich war gerade nur verwirrt, weil ich habe gerade Discord auf.
Habe ich mal... hieß das wirklich Discord?
Oder sage ich jetzt so, Discord, weil ich hier Discord offen habe?
Das...
Was soll das?
Aber zumindest das ist jetzt neu.
Das finde ich gut.
Das sind so Kleinigkeiten, wo ich mir denke...
Warum gab es das nicht schon schneller?
Aber ich will ja nicht so sehr drüber meckern.
Ich bin ja froh, dass es sowas gibt.
Aber das finde ich jetzt eine coole Sache.
Ob das jetzt ein wahnsinniger...
Wahnsinniger Buff ist, kann man sich drüber streiten.
Es ist...
Es ist eigentlich eher nice to have.
Es ist nice to have.
Wenn man jetzt sagt, hey, man spielt mit Absprache und so.
Dann ist das ganz cool.
Dann rennt ein Target um die Ecke.
Und du kannst sagen, ja, okay, Genji ist um die Ecke.
Hat nur noch, keine Ahnung, 10%.
Ist fast tot.
Dann hilft das was.
Also ich würde sagen, das ist so...
Eigentlich hauptsächlich wird eben jemand im Chat geschrieben...
Quality of Life.
Auf so die Schwelle zwischen Quality of Life Change zu Buff.
Aber ich finde, es ist eine coole Änderung.
Es gibt dann sonst so Neues in der Welt von Competitive Overwatch.
Was sind dann hier so die neuesten Gerüchte?
Zeig mal her.
Können wir noch mal gucken, bis der E-Exploder da ist.
Was hat ein Excusi wieder angestellt?
Excusi Band.
Was?
Machen sie wieder Excusi Hexenjagd, die Leute, oder was?
Reddit-Leute sind die Schlimmsten.
Das sind so die ganzen Justice Warrior.
Selbst nichts geschissen kriegen, aber bei anderen immer ganz genau drauf schauen.
Wenn man sich mal überlegt, was Excusi für eine Belastung ausgesetzt ist.
12 Stunden gesammelt.
Das sind so die ganzen Justice Warrior.
Selbst nichts geschissen kriegen, aber bei anderen immer ganz genau drauf schauen.
Wenn man sich mal überlegt, was Excusi für eine Belastung ausgesetzt ist.
12 Stunden gestreamt morgens und abends plus Grimms.
Der macht ja nichts außer Overwatch spielen und pennen.
Und dass man da manchmal ein bisschen stinkig ist auf das Game, kann ich voll und ganz verstehen.
WB.
Können starten.
Discord, zack.
Q.
Anubis, jawoll.
Endlich.
Ich hab schon drauf gewartet.
Komm, Speed, go go.
Volle Pulle rein.
Weißt du, ich hab eigentlich schon seit wir heute angefangen haben,
hab ich mir gedacht, wann kommt endlich meine Lieblingsweb?
Und jetzt ist sie da.
Magst du eigentlich Max?
Ich finde, du wärst so der Typ dafür.
Warum bin ich der Typ für Max?
2CP, lull.
Was sollst du jetzt erklären?
Oh, wir haben ganz gute Setup.
Natürlich, weil du ein trenniger Technik-Hipster bist.
So ist es.
Leaked.
Jetzt ist es raus.
Busted.
Exposed.
Max Exposed.
Ich bin ein trenniger Technik-Hipster.
Also Max sind vor der Hardware tatsächlich nicht übel.
Also ich hätte nix dagegen, den Mag zu benutzen.
Komm, Speed, go go.
Volle Pulle.
In your face, die sind out of position.
D.Va steht unten, die wird jetzt geregt.
D.Va out of mag, zack.
Fuck, ich bin nur sen links, sen links.
Okay.
Werden wir jetzt ab?
Nice picks, nice picks.
Wir regroupen jetzt und kommen wieder richtig fett mit Speed.
Ich versuche dich zu save.
Nope, aber ich nette.
Wir kommen jetzt richtig fett mit Speed.
Fett Speed Boost kann man da jetzt rein.
Ich warte noch auf dich kurz.
Zumindest, wenn du mit Speed aus dem Spawn kommst.
Und jetzt gehen wir voll rein.
Wir gehen volle Pulle rein.
Die sind nämlich noch auf dem Weg hierher.
Oh, go go.
Go Leute.
Warum macht ihr das ewig rum?
Okay.
Das ist total gesplittert.
Nice, nice, nice picks.
Very nice.
Ich hab halt nur 5 HP, ey.
Äh, ich geh, ich...
Oh nein, warte, warte, warte.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Haha.
Der Winston.
5 HP.
Die wollen es aber echt wissen.
Die, die wollen echt...
Wir gehen direkt durch.
Direkt weiter.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein, rein.
What the hell, was ist das für ein Kampf am ersten Punkt?
Keine Ahnung.
Was ist da dran?
So wie lange das geht?
Was geht da ab, ey?
Aber die haben alles raus an Ultimates.
Wenn wir was haben konnten, gehts, gehts was.
Aber wir haben nix.
Oh.
Auf, Jungs, volle Pulle.
Gebt alles, gebt alles.
Spider-Man.
Ganz viel Spider-Man.
Spider-Lucio.
Sag mal, Leute, geht halt auf den verfuckten Punkt.
Weißt, die springen da 3 Stunden in den Turn rum und die da so, jetzt können wir mal
vorgehen.
Need Healing, Need Healing.
Ja, Kollege.
Das war, wie sie schneller reingehen sollen.
Kannst runterhüpfen, dann wirst du, geil.
Nice, nice, nice hinterher.
Follow up.
Go, go.
Jungs, go, go.
Ich hab da wieder Ult.
Ich lenke den Soldier ab.
Der will mich.
Fuck, fuck, fuck, nooo.
Kurz vor Ult.
Man hört Soldier69 nicht, der sagt auch grad nix.
Wenn er was sagt, dann hört er ihn wieder.
Jetzt habt ihr gehört, oder?
Heal.
Ja, das war das Beste zu sagen, ne?
Ich quike hier wie so ein Schwein.
Fuck, ey.
Puh.
Die Mercy ist ja gar nicht da.
Der Winston, Winston.
Okay, okay.
Go, Attacke.
Ich stürz.
Wo sind sie denn?
Pass auf, Genji kommt zu dir hoch.
Okay, vielleicht hab ich das ein bisschen falsch eingeschätzt.
Also das ist ja eines der chaotischsten...
Wie ist die Mercy da jetzt gestorben, ey?
Das ist eines der chaotischsten 2CP-Matches, das ich je hatte.
Das war ein perfekter Aimpunch.
Okay.
Jetzt, Jungs.
Boah, es ist einer tot.
Ich hab gleich wieder Ulti.
Ich hab gleich Soundbarrier.
Nice.
3 Soundbarriers zum Schluss, ey.
Das ging ab.
Das war eines der wirrsten 2CP-Runden aller Zeiten.
Das war eigentlich von Anfang bis Ende ein Feind, oder?
Gefühlt.
Irgendwie schon, ja.
Little Samsung, ja, da hast du recht.
Ach, da, wer kommt mir der Name bekannt vor?
Du hattest mir mal ein Gameplay geschickt, ne?
Hab ich dir gesagt, du grindest zu wenig an den Wänden lang?
Na, ich hab da die übelste Spider-Man-Action gerade gemacht.
Du musst ja keine halbe Stunde an den Wänden lang grinden.
Es geht ja nur darum, dass du an die Wände springst, Speedboost kriegst und wieder abhaust.
Ähm...
Wollen wir mal Symmetra spielen?
Nee, das Ganze knicken.
Wenn die Gegner rein daifen, ist halt immer so...
Boah.
Das ist eine große Analyse.
Niemals stopfst du mit dem, wofür du glaubst.
Reinhard, ich muss dir sagen, du siehst ziemlich gut aus.
Wird die Overwatch-School wieder aufleben, ja, wenn ich wieder besser bin?
Dann machen wir vielleicht doch mal wieder ein paar Gameplay-Analysen.
Huge Ana-Picks.
Huge Sleep-Darts kommen jetzt.
Massive, massive Sleep-Darts, ich sag's euch.
Was ich jetzt oft gesehen hab, sind, dass da oben, da wo du stehst,
die Widow steht eine Orissa unten und macht ein Shield hier oben vor die Sniper und die DS.
Und steht dann irgendwo an der Treppe hier rum, dass sie nicht getroffen werden kann.
Schau, ist jetzt locker seit 5 Jahren, so siehst du zum ersten Mal den Stream.
Ähm...
Ja, du kannst mir followen auf Twitch, ich bin relativ oft online in letzter Zeit.
Eigentlich fast jeden Tag jetzt in den letzten paar Tagen gewesen.
Ist die Sniper-Action schon am Start?
Nice Pick.
Haben wir eine Widow?
Ja, haben sie.
Achtung Winston, Harambe.
Huge Sleep...
Oh fuck, fuck, fuck, der Sleep, der ging in die Bubble.
Ich seh dich nicht.
Nice.
Sleep.
Mercy, nicht pieken, nicht pieken.
Huge Razz.
Wo ist denn die Widow, siehst du die?
Äh, hier, hier flitzt irgendwo eine...
Die Widow ist unten links.
Alter, meine Sleep-Darts sind ja räudig gerade.
Nix mit Huge Sleep-Darts.
Reinhardt!
Oh shit.
Alter!
Jetzt hitt ich mal einen und Sleep mich selbst.
Ich hab meine Anubis aufgehoben anstatt sie jetzt zu wasen am ersten Punkt.
Die war kein Mick.
Wir machen jetzt Huge 6 Minuten Defense.
Pass auf.
Oh, ich seh dich nicht. Mercy, hübsch auch nicht so rum.
Out of Mag.
Was ist diese scheiß Scheiße?
Ich war gerade auf dem Punkt, ich glaub die ist rechts.
Ich glaub die ist rechts hin in diesen Raum.
Da, halt.
Was das heißt.
Wat?
Ich guck mal um die Ecke ob die da rechts irgendwo rumgammelt.
Ja.
Das ist rechts.
Genji kommt rein.
Sieht aus als hätte er einen Ult.
Ein Aircraft.
Sleep, Sleep, Sleep.
Hinter uns noch ein Affe, noch ein Affe.
Oh, ein Affe und Mercy.
War ein XTP.
Soldier.
Da ist noch was hinten gewesen, oder?
Hab ich mich da verguckt.
Ne, wir haben beides.
Nice, nice, nice, nice picks.
Huge picks.
Fuck.
Huge Dress.
Ich spam einfach mal Heal auf dich, easy.
Der ist an dir vorbei gesprungen.
Könnt ihr mal pushen?
Fuck.
Oh, wir sauen.
Ich glaub du kriegst gleich nen Rats.
Äh, Soldier-Advisor, der wird jetzt Genanoboosted.
Wo ist er denn?
Da isser.
Soldier, ich seh dich da noch net.
Okay, das war ein bisschen Aufwand.
Oh, ich bin gesniped um links, Sniper.
Oh, Sherino.
You would sleep.
Fuck.
Ich hab nicht geguckt.
Ne, ich hab mich selber ins Hang gegillt.
Pass auf, pass auf.
Ich seh dich nicht, hier stehen so viele Leute vor dir.
Bist du wieder voll?
Wo ist denn der Reinhardt-Shield, warum?
Der ist down.
Ich hab gleich wieder, gleich wieder Dings hier.
Der Soldier hat auch Ulti, nice.
Gut.
So, wir haben auch Nanoboost für den letzten Fight, falls die nochmal rankommen sollten.
Easy, easy win.
Jetzt kommt's.
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding.
Wird erstmal verfehlt.
Ja.
Blink, wenigstens der Zweite, ja.
Ja, der Lucio ist auch noch mitgekommen.
Wenigstens der Zweite.
Du bist echt gut, auch wenn die Darts eher selten treffen, spielst du das sehr überlegt.
Dankeschön.
Ja, die Darts müssen noch ein bisschen genauer sein, aber ich übertreib's auch manchmal.
Ich versuch bei Anna meistens die total sinnlos schweren Darts, anstatt auf das Ziel zu gehen, was einfach zu treffen ist.
Aber das gab ordentlich jetzt.
HugeSR gab das.
Der Smurf, ja, ich Smurfe nicht.
Ich hab seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt und wieder neuen Account gewonnen.
Also ich finde, das ist ein Unterschied.
Smurfen ist für mich jemand, weil man keine Ahnung wann spielt, man hat einen GM-Account und denkt,
hey, ich will jetzt mal ein paar Platz und Diamonds wrecken.
Das ist für mich Smurfen.
Nicht, ich hab ein halbes Jahr nicht gespielt nach meinem neuen Account, dass ich wieder in das Game reinkomme.
Ich finde, das ist schon so ein kleiner Unterschied.
Wo ist Mercy?
Oh, tmr, bist du für Mercy Mainstream gekommen?
Mal gucken, ob wir das nachher wieder rausholen können.
Ich muss kurz Chat lesen, dass ich mal wieder unten angelangt bin im Chat.
Kann ich mir den Kaffee machen?
Dann mute ich mich kurz.
Viel Spaß.
Dann schau mal nicht lieber Adelaide zu, der sagt Huge alle paar Sekunden.
Ja, der übertreibt.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, dieses Huge und Massive und dieses Gelaber, da habe ich mich aus englischen Streams anstecken lassen.
Das ist schlimm.
Das ist echt schlimm.
Doch, was ich richtig affig finde, ist die ganzen Typen, die immer anfangen, My Doggy.
Das hat XQ7 mal damit angefangen und alle sagen sie jetzt blablabla, My Doggy.
Das finde ich richtig hängen geblieben.
Was ist das für ein Windstreak?
Das ist sogar noch ein höherer Windstreak.
Was ist heute? Viel Scootman Windstreak.
Eigentlich sind es ja sechs, ne?
Ihr seht ja auch krasse mathematische Formel, sieben mal sechs.
Eigentlich ist es ja nur sechs, weil das eine Game war ja nur fürs Gewissen.
Das war ja abgebrochen.
Warum bist du noch kein Affiliate Partner bei Twitch? Sollte doch schon funktionieren.
Funktioniert schon seit Monaten.
Zeigt es mir an, willst nicht Affiliate werden.
Ich überlege mir vielleicht Partner zu werden, wenn sich da die Gelegenheit ergibt.
Ich versuche jetzt aber erst mal hier ordentlich ein bisschen Routine rein kriegen in das Ganze.
Dass ich so meinen Rhythmus finde regelmäßig, weil jeden Tag Streamen kriege ich nicht hin.
Vielleicht kriege ich das jeden zweiten, jeden dritten Tag hin, muss ich mal gucken.
Dann will ich auch so die Viewer-Base so ein bisschen ausbauen und dann mal gucken, Partner.
Wer mich suppen will, geht gerade nicht.
Aber wenn ihr mir doch irgendwie was zukommen lassen wollt, könnt ihr auf der Profilseite auf den Donation-Link klicken und mir was donaten.
Aber wie gesagt, ich bin froh über alle, die zugucken, es muss hier keiner irgendwie was abdrücken oder so.
Irgendwie seltsam, obwohl Rank so scheiße ist, Max spielt wieder Overwatch, Killsen spielt wieder Overwatch, ist da was im Busch.
Wahrscheinlich hoffen wir alle drauf, dass es demnächst ein Ranked-System-Rework gibt.
Und dann vielleicht eine Team-Q kommt oder ob das dann das Ranked-System wieder huge und geil und toll ist.
So, wir wollten uns ja mal die neuesten Overwatch-Gerüchte und so angucken.
Was gibt's denn, was haben wir denn hier?
Was ich zu sie wieder angestellt habe, haben wir nicht rausgekriegt.
Ähm...
Little Samson sagt, am besten ist es rein, einen Charge anzubieten, wenn er ihn annimmt, ihm den Dart in die Fresse zu hauen.
Ja, oder was auch gut ist, einfach durch das Reinhardt-Schild durchlaufen.
Was hältst du von Moira?
Kaum gespielt, außer ein bisschen Quickplay.
Ich sehe noch nicht, wie krass Moira kommt, aber warten wir mal die nächsten Pro-Matches ab.
Schon mitbekommen, dass die Amerikaner Zeit...
Ah, ich hab Zeit, ich fasse Zeit, Netzneutralität abgeschafft haben laut Zeit.de abgeschafft haben.
Ja, ich wusste, dass der gegen eine Abstimmung ist.
Ich hab 3 Smurfs, Top 500, da bin ich wohl falsch mit Smurfen.
Yup.
Brauchste noch einen vierten Account?
Ähm...
Guckst du die dritte Staffel von Mr. Robot?
Ich hab noch nicht mal die zweite Staffel geguckt, weil mich das Ende von Staffel 1 so enttäuscht hat.
Die letzten paar Folgen von Staffel 1 fand ich kacke.
Da ging es nur noch darum, was der Held für einen Dachschaden hat.
So war.
Und mit möglichst wenig Spoiler, jetzt versuche ich das mal.
Und die letzte Folge hat mich total enttäuscht.
Die ganze Serie arbeitet auf so ein Ereignis hin, ja, was dann auch in der letzten Folge oder zwischen Vorletzter und letzter Folge so passiert.
Und der Held verschleft es.
WTF, was ist das?
Da hab ich mir die zweite Staffel nicht mal angeguckt.
Das Ende von Mr. Robot 1 hat mich echt enttäuscht.
So, was gibt's denn für neue Overwatch Gerüchte?
Zeig mal her.
Ähm...
Rascal reported Exclusive for throwing.
Aha.
Exclusive ist halt schon das riesen Thema hier auf Overwatch heute.
Jedenfalls die Leute auf der Pressekonferenz...
Juckt mich nicht.
Wir müssen eh warten bis Eaxe wieder da ist, dass wir weiter queueen können.
Braucht jedes Team Psychologen.
Äh...
Ich glaube nicht, dass jedes Team Psychologen braucht.
Sondern einzelne Spieler, wenn sie das Bedürfnis haben, einen besuchen sollten.
PTR Update.
Ok, was gibt's da Neues?
Ja, das kennen wir schon. Das haben wir doch eben schon gesehen.
Gibt's sonst noch irgendwas?
Das ist echt ein Problem.
Es gibt viel zu wenig Turniere in Overwatch.
Eigentlich müsste Blizzard ein großes Interesse daran haben, dass es Competition auf allen Level gibt in Overwatch.
Weil keiner fängt an, Competitive zu spielen, ist hier gleich der krasse Overwatch-League-Owner.
Es müsste Competition auf allen Level geben in Overwatch.
Und es gibt viel zu wenig Turniere.
Und es gibt auch viel zu wenig kleine Turniere.
Ich meine, damit es nicht unbedingt Platin-Turniere oder sowas.
Aber es müsste Competition auf allen Level geben.
Nur das wird dazu führen, dass Overwatch langfristig auch erfolgreich sein wird.
Aber mit dem E-Sport-Management und der Geschichte von Blizzard, ihr wisst, dass ich da nicht so zuversichtlich bin.
Man guckt sich mal an, was aus StarCraft II geworden ist.
Hast du Tipps, wie man im Rank schneller hochkommt?
Was könnte da der beste Tipp sein?
Außer sich Carrying lassen.
So wie mich Eax Carried.
Was könnte das Beste sein?
Also neben diesen Standarddingern, wie natürlich viel spielen, ist klar.
Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist, dass man sich selbst darüber im Klaren wird.
Oder dass man sich selbst realistisch einschätzen kann.
Ich glaube, das ist das Wichtigste.
Nicht nur bei Overwatch, bei vielen Sachen und bei vielen Games.
Es hat keinen Sinn, wenn man quasi nur sagt, es liegt an den Teammates.
Das ist in Overwatch leider so.
Das Ranking-System in Overwatch ist absolute Krutze.
Total beschissen.
Das ist Cancer und Tilt hoch 3.
Aber man muss sich selbst ganz gut einschätzen können.
Also sprich, es sind nicht immer nur die Teammates schuld dran, dass man gewonnen hat.
Ich glaube, es ist wichtig, dass man selbst erkennt, wann man Scheiße baut.
Und das sollte man sich auch eingestehen.
Wenn man Scheiße gebaut hat.
Weil nur dann wird man besser.
Übrigens, weil Leute nach einer Sombra-Comp gefragt haben.
Mal gucken, ob es das auf YouTube gibt.
Dallas Fuel vs...
Was war das?
Was ist das Team von Mendo?
Wobei, waren die das?
Die haben ja nicht Junkertown Sombra gespielt.
Das können wir uns mal kurz angucken, was die für eine Comp gespielt haben.
Was war denn das?
Dallas Fuel vs...
Gucken wir mal kurz.
Dallas...
Florida Mayhem, genau.
Florida...
Junkertown.
Ach so, ich bin eigentlich bescheuert.
Ich war gerade auf der richtigen Seite schon und suche hier auf Google rum.
Hier, erstes Match Junkertown war das.
Da hat Dallas Moira und Sombra und so komische Dinger gespielt.
Ganz merkwürdiges Setup, was man so nicht gesehen hat.
Hier, guckt.
Moira...
Moira, D.Va, Tracer, Roadhog, Sombra, Lucio.
Und nachdem es Dallas Fuel ist, sie haben sich 100% was dabei gedacht.
Ich kann mir da nur so ein paar Sachen auswahlen, wie nach dem Motto...
Relativ close range Tank.
Bisschen Flanker Action und Moira kann halt auch ganz gut diese zwei Tanks heilen.
Und halt auch gegen Bastion ganz gut.
Also so wirklich 100% den Geniestreich an dieser Comp, der ist mir auch nicht ganz klar.
Aber nachdem Dallas Fuel...
Ich meine, ich spiele ja auch nicht wahnsinnig auf dem Level.
Nachdem Dallas Fuel gespielt hat, haben sie sich mit Sicherheit was dabei gedacht.
Es ist aber nicht aufgegangen.
Sie wurden hardcore gerekt.
Ja.
PTR. Gibt's PTR? Other changes.
PTR Change, was gibt's denn da?
Oh nein, bitte nicht noch mehr Doomfist Bugs.
Bitte nicht mehr Doomfist Bugs.
Das Doomfist ist jetzt schon absolut nervig zu spielen und dagegen zu spielen.
So, ich bin wieder da.
WB. Dann können wir ja...
Chat, stimmt 7-0 oder habe ich irgendwas vergessen?
Ich glaube, das stimmt. Ich glaube, 7-0.
Du bist gemutet, falls du was sagst.
Ja, ich bin gemutet.
Es ist 7-0, glaube ich jetzt. 7-0.
Wir haben 7 Games gemacht. Kommt das hin?
Zumindest haben wir nichts verloren.
Nichts verloren, ja.
Gut, easy. Ich cue.
Oh, das geht. Jetzt wo wir es gerade von Junkertown haben...
Komm, Bastion Strats.
Ich kann nicht schon wieder...
Defense. Ich kann die Defense Strats nicht.
Die Defense Bastion Strats.
Weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Oh, haben wir Mercy Main?
Ich hoffe doch.
Nein.
I need healing. Das kriegt doch noch Mercy Main.
Gar nichts.
Ich geh mal in Teamchat.
Wer vorhin geschrieben hat, ich muss noch mal in diese Option...
Man konnte doch irgendwie ausstellen, dass man mit Mercy immer zu dem Target fliegt, wo man den Strahl drauf hat.
Weißt du, unter welchen Settings das ist?
Das täte ich auch mal interessiert.
Das ist irgendetwas. Das geht. Das habe ich letztens irgendwo gelesen. Das muss ich ausschalten.
Wo ist das? Controls?
Muss man Mercy auswählen, oder steht es...
Ha!
Jawoll. Nice.
Weil dann kann ich nämlich zu jemand anderem fliegen und weiter heilen.
Das muss ich mir noch merken für meinen Mainaccount.
So, jetzt könnt ihr wieder huge Mercy Plays sehen.
Ich geh mal oben drauf.
Rektorino.
Schild ist auch versetzt für die Bastion.
Sag mir, wenn du Hilfe... Oh, Tracer von Netten.
Hilfe!
Der Firestrike.
Ich war auf dir drauf.
Piss dich, piss dich.
Du musst wieder vorne in Disengagement, sonst staggert er.
Ach, wir staggern.
Ich bevorzuge zu staggern. Ich finde das ist besser.
Nein.
Fail.
Oh, die gehen nochmal zum Contesten.
Okay, dann ziehe ich dich vor.
Scheiße. Die gehen nicht mehr zum Contesten.
Er hat zu lange gestaggert.
Wo bist du?
Ich hab nur Reinhardt hier bei mir.
Ich weiß nicht, wo du bist. Wo bist du?
Ach, da oben. Warte mal, ich komm mal zu dir hoch. Du kannst mich hochfliegen lassen.
Passt, passt, passt.
Die haben die Bastion-Stats nicht so richtig drauf.
Ich glaub, die will zu mir hoch.
Fuck!
Ich zieh wieder hoch.
Leute, Contested, Contested.
Ich hab gleich Ulti.
Ich bleib auf dir mit Beam.
Gucken wir mal, dass die nicht unten durchflanken, die gleich hinter uns lang kommen.
Sniper?
Ja.
Du musst aufpassen, dass ich nicht in die Sonne laufe.
Ach komm, ich hab auch abgedrückt. Fuck off.
Kannst du mich heilen?
Ich bin vorne bei der D.Va.
Ich bin bei dir.
Nein, sie wurde auch... Fuck.
Oh fuck, ich hab kein Rätsel mehr.
Schon wieder, ey.
Ich kann dich gleich rätseln.
Sie nutzt halt den Crackling Hook nur für mich.
Mega ärgerlich.
Links, links, links.
Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen...
Ist alles unter dir.
Wir müssen ein bisschen zurück.
Ich komm zu dir hoch.
Komm da weg.
Ich muss die D.Va heilen.
Ich muss zu dir hoch. Fuck, das hab ich nicht.
Help Leute.
Ich kann nicht zu dir fliegen, das ist mein Problem.
Das ist so chaotisch.
Ich seh nix wegen dem Penis Tracer, ey.
Das war ne Scheiß-Old von mir.
Wo ist denn der Verkackte?
Da is er.
Oh, jetzt hat er in eine Runde gezweigt.
Echt.
Gut, Schmarcy Plays.
Was ist das?
Plane that child.
Du hast Damage Boost.
Kann ich mich hoch?
Nein, ich muss hier unten drinnen heilen.
Ich komm zu dir.
Kannst du die D.Va nicht mitnehmen?
Da war ich ganz wenig Einfluss drauf.
Nächstes Mal sagst du mir Bescheid, ich komm zu dir mit der D.Va.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die da ist.
Die haben keine Winner mehr.
Wo bist du? Kommst du vom Spawn?
Du lebst noch.
Die Ana blockt.
Tracer, Tracer.
Oh, rekt.
Hat er richtig gut gestalt. Vielleicht kriegen wir das jetzt.
Ana, huge Plays, Ana.
Nein, mit dem Junkrat nicht.
Ich glaube, da war ich gehabt.
Das war aber eine super Zeit für den zweiten Punkt.
Wenigstens schlägt keine Bastion mehr auf der Payload.
Das ist schonmal was.
Nicht, dass die jetzt auf die D.Va kommen zu switchen.
Oben, links, Roadhog.
Weißt du?
Ich versuch dich zu boosten.
Ich muss halt bloß jemanden den Shield aufmachen, dann hab ich Impact.
Was geht denn da eigentlich gerade ab?
Tracer?
Oh, Leute.
Voll reingeflogen.
Der Junkrat trifft nix, trifft gar nix.
Auf, Leute. Ich mach jetzt huge, huge, huge Reds.
Jetzt muss einer dran gehen. Vielleicht kann das nicht.
Ah, ich wurd gefickt.
Der Junkrat kommt mit dem Tire. Das könnte was werden.
Ich komm mal mit Speed wieder.
Was?
Nice, C9.
Ah, C9, sehr schön.
Das Einzige, was er im Voice Chat gesagt hat, die ganze Runde war C9 eben, der Typ.
Richtig, C9.
Komm, komm, wir machen die Bastion.
Bastion Strats.
Jaja, können die ja machen. Ich lenk dann den Gegner ab.
Muss halt bloß noch einer in 6.
Wir brauchen nur Mercy.
Ah, ich Mercy.
Weil die richtig pro Bastion Strats sind ja Orisa plus Reinhard.
Plus Winston.
Nein.
Aber da kommt Defense Matrix noch dabei.
Ja, Moira macht schon ordentlich Damage, aber das ist ja auch mit Konzept von diesem Held, dass du ja quasi so Mana Ressourcen hast, wo du healen kannst und wieder Mana saugen kannst von Gegnern.
Also musst du ein bisschen was machen.
AD Spam.
Ich brauch ne neue Tastatur, dass ich schneller AD Spam kann.
Ich booste mal ne Runde am Anfang, ne?
Booste Reno.
Ja, Koka, du hast nur der Fokus auf das Thema als auf mich.
Ja, am Anfang kriegst du jetzt erst mal.
Am Anfang kannst du jetzt erst mal schön alles schnipsern.
Moin, Dag, Fabsi.
Wo ist denn Genji hinter uns?
Ja, rechts, Alter.
Oh, oh, oh, von rechts, von links ne Mei.
Irgendwo, irgendwas hat mich da grad Eis angehauen.
Oh, saug woanders dran.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, Mei, Mei, Mei.
Von hinten, von hinten ne Mei.
Was? Wieso hat das nicht getroffen?
Hä?
Ich bin immer noch hier hinten bei D.Va im Haus.
Und hier Tracer noch bei uns.
Ich mein, wir sind mega lang auseinandergezogen.
Irgendwo ist noch ne Tracer zwischen hier und mir.
Ja, bei mir.
Direkt.
Bestchen oben rechts da.
Ich kann dich nicht boosten.
Ich seh dich schnell.
Ich geh.
Tracer hinter dir, geh weg da.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich hin soll.
Nee, ich kann den konstant nirgendswo hin.
Die Tracer trifft aber nicht gut.
Ich bin noch nicht da.
Nice, nice, nice pick.
Was?
Mach doch mal die Mei tot, Leute.
What the fuck?
So.
Gute Zeit, gute Zeit.
Die könnte sein, dass die noch mal kommen.
Zeit genug hätten sie.
Aber dann halt ohne Mei.
Kommst du hoch?
Hier lang.
Ich muss mal heilen hier hinten.
Ich hab boost auf dir.
Ich muss heilen, ich muss heilen unten.
Die Mei ist noch oben bei dir.
Die Mei ist immer noch oben.
Oben bei mir ist die Mei.
Ich bin unten.
Der besten Flank war fail.
Ich guck mal, ob ich den gerätst kriege.
Nein.
C9, auch gut.
Easy win.
Was denn heut los?
Keine Ahnung, winning streak heißt.
Ab geht's.
Also ich weiß nicht, was heut los ist.
Aber so einen krassen winning streak hatten wir noch nie.
Ich muss mich mal selbst liken.
Wegen den absoluten Massive-Mersi-Plays.
Keiner liket mich.
Das 64 reicht auch nicht.
Ja, das ist nicht likewürdig.
Während es jetzt 64% Crit Rate.
Mal gucken, wie viel es gab.
3800 Punkte, genau.
Zack.
Was, warum?
Warum kriegst du so viel mehr?
Du bist jetzt 138 Punkte drüber.
Ziehen wir mal 50 ab.
Trotzdem.
Eigentlich so gesehen 238, wie wir angefangen haben.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Chef, fail.
Ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ich würde fast sagen, dass wir jetzt Schluss machen.
Ich muss jetzt eh gleich Wunderabend essen, duschen und Zeug machen.
Noch was aufnehmen.
Das reicht.
8 Games, flawless Victory-Tag heute.
Huge Plays.
Übrigens, Patrick, weil ich dich gerade im Chat sehe.
Sorry, dass ich deine Donation nicht gesehen hab letztens.
Der alte Max hätte 10-0.
Tja, kann ich alles haben.
Dafür gab es Huge Mercy Plays.
Und die Leitung ist nicht abgekackt heute.
Das scheint doch was mit den Settings zu tun zu haben.
Bei mir ist auch nichts abgekackt.
Verwunderlich.
Wie macht man eigentlich Rates in Twitch, wenn ich jetzt einen anderen Channel raiden will?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Ich werde einfach jetzt mal irgendjemanden.
Vergiss deine Keks-Rate-Nachricht nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Ich bin da viel zu nupt für.
Gibst du dein Chat-Nachricht Keks-Rate oder was?
Ach so, ja.
Slash-Rate-Name und was passiert dann?
Opossum TS, was passiert dann?
Kriegt der dann irgendwas angezeigt oder was?
Ich holste euch jetzt mal jemand.
Ich glaube, das ist ein Österreicher.
Allerdings macht er einen englischsprachigen Stream.
Macht super educational Content.
Kabaji, glaube ich, spricht man ihn aus.
Guck ich immer gerne.
Hat auch einen YouTube-Channel.
Ansonsten, ich hoffe euch hat das Stream gefallen.
Wer noch nicht gefollowed ist, denkt dran.
Und macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.
Und gebt ihm mal mit die Message Keks-Rate.
Und gebt ihm mal mit die Message Keks-Raid!
Bis dann, Tschüss!
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken...
Es war nice heute, oder?
Ja, ging gut rein.
War echt sehr nice.
Weil manchmal bin ich so ein bisschen enttäuscht, da könnte noch so viel mehr gehen, aber es geht einfach nicht so.
Aber es lief halt echt gut.
So, ich bin mal kurz noch im Klo.